in the Indian Ocean a garden is being
grown underwater
this conservationists spent most of
their days nurturing and tending to
corals that have been damaged
the fishing community of kuruitu has set
aside this space to save struggling
corals and bring them back to life
is one environmentalist who's helping
with this loss of coral you're also
looking at wave action you know for
example from things like tsunamis and
other high tide action that goes away
putting Coastal communities and
settlements at risk 25 of the world's
marine life lives among coral reefs
rooted to the ocean floor
these corals are dead you can tell from
their color it's going to take many
years to replant others and repairing
the damage that has been caused is hard
work
[Music]
being able to take our artificial leaves
that we've designed are either into the
water clean those observe look at the
health as they're growing so it's an
everyday thing
it's intensive it's been six years since
people here started restoring life in
these Waters they say they're now seeing
more fish and businesses are doing
better
sometimes I catch four octopus it takes
me a while because I have to rush to
beat the high tide on average I make
about ten dollars a day did
many of those who panned the garden are
former fishermen they say what they're
doing is working towards numbers are
rising
and their Community is thriving
Catherine soy Al Jazeera kilifi County